be a good [ __ ] human being and try to
put others in a position to succeed
watch miraculously how that works for
you that's what's about to happen
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
[Music]
an hour and a half ago yes in and out
but all good it's on time I'm going to
be right on stage
let's do it
execution you know nothing like out of
the ordinary per se it's more just about
making sure be friends and banner X do
what they need to be doing
you know
[Music]
Gary vaynerchuk and with all the bad
news in web 3 lately what would you say
to the Skeptics
not much you know I don't really have a
lot of interest in debating when I
launched an e-commerce website in 1997
and all the internet stocks collapsed in
2000 and people asked me what now
I didn't have time to explain to them
that nothing's different the short-term
greed of the Gold Rush of the last year
in nft land
doesn't change the macro technology and
consumer impact I appreciate their
skepticism I think there was a ton of
bad behavior I think people got ahead of
themselves I think greed confused a lot
of people but I have no interest in
debating the outcome I just have focus
on executing so I'm there for the
outcome thank you so much thank you have
the best day
how's it been going good job
[Applause]
you know I I definitely don't always win
but I'm always but I'm always playing to
win
you know like I want to win like I want
my companies to be the biggest I want to
win it's my game like what are we doing
here it's a game I want to win I don't
think that's a bad thing I'm fiercely
competitive however
I do think that for me at least I don't
think my winning comes out of anybody
else's pocket so for me it's like I'm
gonna win but I want everybody else to
win too in the agency land when we pitch
a new piece of business if another
agency wins all right like we lost like
we didn't tell the client what they
wanted here they went somewhere else
it's not like I hate Johnny or Ricky you
know I get pumped watching all these
projects do well I don't think the
friends not being the number one valued
project is bad like I think when all the
dust settles in 22 years you're going to
forget about a lot of names that we [ __ ]
with today and I'm gonna be [ __ ]
dominated but if I don't
I'm gonna be pumped for World of women
or board ape or you know whoever are
like yeah like I I don't I'm surprised
that people don't know how to balance
trying to be successful and enjoying
their process and loving their game and
being competitive with also being okay
for rooting for everyone else including
people that are direct competitors I
just think the world is abundant and I
I'm gonna get mine nobody's stopping me
from getting mine which is why I cheer
for everybody else to get theirs
thank you everyone
[Applause]
who do I make it out to my friend Harry
I've been learning from you so much man
this is a dream come true thank you so
much
thank you brother hope you heal up
oh boom okay you don't you don't need
the mic right you're not coming to this
me I have to go this week as well
[Music]
Palmer
the whole friction
[Music]
all right daily B first of all because
Justin's here and I know what kind of
cult hero he is so I figured just just
to get some views I might use this as a
thumbnail I don't want you to steal my
thunder uh so what we're about to do is
we're about to sit down I do these
things called Jam sessions with CMOS and
Business Leaders where we just all get
together and we talk about current
events and like
right officially this is called wine and
what's next and we do this under vaynerx
but I do it in all parts of my life not
just the vaynermedia side a bunch of
CMOS a bunch of people from my company
and literally like I'll get everybody
quiet and I'll say one conversation all
right let's talk about what's happening
with Tick Tock let's talk about what's
happening what do you think's gonna
happen with Twitter and Elon hey what do
you think's gonna happen with CTV
connected TV no more TV commercials all
of it it's gonna be on Hulu Netflix you
know peacock Amazon Prime and we'll just
Jam two three hours but what's best of
all is like people make relationships
they do this for a decade really
hardcore for the last five years people
have gotten their next job from people
they've met here people have like
learned something that impacted their
Campaign which put them on the map that
got them their next opportunity this is
a big night of relationship and Karma
building and for a lot of entrepreneurs
that are watching right now I think
everyone's too transactional like
tonight I don't sit here and say all
right this 14 000 meal because a bunch
of wine a bunch of people uh got to
cover it all big tip like I'm like what
did we get out of that did we get 37 000
did we get 77 000 for that 14k We're not
gonna get [ __ ] out of it today we may
never get anything out of it that's okay
but we might also get a six million
dollar client from it in three years
because of tonight we may
I just think that too many people are
transactional what's in it for me right
now very quickly and for me back to the
marathon versus the Sprint this is like
how do I bring as much value to as many
people here as humanly possible by
educating them by trying to match them
together hey uh Herm from DraftKings me
you know meet uh Sanborn from Diageo
maybe that leads to I saw something huge
come out huge come out in the streaming
Sports face
three four weeks ago a hundred percent
because of something I put together
no referral fee no [ __ ] credit no
nothing and I don't give a [ __ ] I'm not
living [ __ ] life for credit or for
[ __ ] money I'm living it for like
[ __ ] putting goodness into the world
I know how to get mine I'll get mine the
more you do good you'll get yours in the
pockets
if you [ __ ] focus on your heart
and so tonight's about a whole bunch of
karma getting together putting people in
the right position mentally but talking
about current events the amount of
people that moved on Tick Tock three
years ago because of a dinner like this
that ain't one the amount of people that
did X Y and Z and because my core
strength and that's my organization's
core strength is being the most
contemporary the most [ __ ] on it not
too futuristic and definitely not
looking at the past but being about
today
we're able to curate these kind of
conversations and bring a lot of value
for the people in this room and on top
of it Mom and Dad are in the [ __ ]
building tonight which you can imagine
brings a hell a lot of value but like
right now MJ just point at it right
there MJ Mima is having a conversation
she's been with us for seven years at
Vayner she's having a conversation with
a potential client
I feel no stress around my collar
whether we're gonna do business with
that lady or not none doesn't even
register
do I logically understand them hitting
look what they're doing they're sharing
numbers show it they're sharing this is
[ __ ] meta as [ __ ]
they're sharing numbers right now
do I know that it might
of course I do but do I also know that
some of my best friends in the world
that run decision making at companies
don't pick vaynermedia because maybe
they think we're too close and they
shouldn't maybe they just don't think
we're good enough it happens and this is
what it is stop [ __ ] keeping score
all the time about everything you do
stop being [ __ ] so transactional stop
being so [ __ ] calculated you're not
being clever you're being manipulative
you're not being clever you're being
manipulated
[ __ ] focus on providing value to
human beings I promise you it will be
every [ __ ] sales sorry my guy I'm so
sorry it will beat every [ __ ] sales
strategy you've ever come up with be a
good [ __ ] human being and try to put
others in a position to succeed watch
miraculously how that works for you
that's what's about to happen
[Music]
team I want to think about Tick Tock I
don't want to be known to an entire
generation as the garage sale guy or you
know that I want to be the kind Warrior
kindness you know letting all those
things but a [ __ ] business success
foreign
[Music]